you
hi everyone it's Jeremiah and chess comm
and I just got paired up playing a 3-2
game
let's try eform okay Sicilian probably
going to enter something sharp or not
okay so actually I have a little bit of
experience with this the last standard
game I played was this a same position
okay by this time with d5 instead of
Knight to f6 so different different pawn
structure for sure playing against an
isolated deep on soon
that's just castle I'll take on c5 only
after the Bishop has moved or at least I
only consider doing that after the
Bishop has moved rook to e1 some
candidate moves coming up rook to e1
Bishop g5 I'd welcome a dark square
Bishop exchange so I could rely upon a
piece on d4 a bit easier let's see what
they come up with
Oh h6 that's interesting huh I guess
they don't want Bishop g5 okay I so I
guess I'm rook to e1 Bishop e6 um should
probably still do this stolen file okay
and hmm I
about Bishop III Bishop d6 let's go for
hmm let's go what's Bishop f4 actually
see if they take I think that just
helped me Knight d4 hitting the knight
on c6 and the bishop okay hmm and I'm
gonna play this a little bit aggressive
I may be giving up my bishop pair I'm
gonna try to maybe exploit the King
position still being in the center
giving up my bishop now I don't know how
big a deal this should be and or this
will be we're gonna find out let's take
and let's play Knight here for preparing
night b3 and then maybe sinking into
this square King is still in the center
I don't know if a castling queenside
would be a good option for them
mm-hmm I could play takes Knight b3
let's let's try this
giving up my center point but I have a
pretty direct follow-up Knight d4 or
Bishop here hmm change of plan let's
play on these dark squares c5 and d4
really good homes for my Knights Supreme
of this their King will probably end up
stepping up to d6 I'm not sure
ooh how are they castling let's
with this seems very annoying no good
drop back if Knight e4 or d7 to a3 the
bishop on a3 by the way would be
conveniently there to defend b2 in case
there's a some pressure let's come all
the way back I'm not missing any Forks
d2 covered Knight c5 Knight here I think
I like this move yeah this one so that I
could prepare to Katie give this night a
kick hitting the bish hump my knight
will be in a pin but I think this should
be alright they have to address this
this move first I should be better here
nice c5 humming dark square control I
have a dark square bishop and an
enormous night here on d4 hmm Knight c5
mm yeah probably so they're gonna pop a
knight right into that c4 square I think
maybe not actually b3 this Bishop is
tough to challenge okay they have they
have Knight b7 that but that's super
awkward
maybe I play King here prove the king
position a little bit all right
hmm do I really have to go anywhere with
my bishop let's go for
this hmm
v5 I'm considering be 585 I'm gonna do
this I could eventually force their hand
on a 583 if they prepared this doubling
stuff on the a file at night B 3 maybe I
missed no actually a night a 3 and then
okay change of plan
I was gonna say a night B 3 and then
back the bishop up night C 5 that may be
an idea right now I want to get my
knight to c5 he's more it'll be more of
a pain this also prevents the break a 5
g 4 might be an idea just to take away
some squares a knight here probably
Bishop d4 should I play a 4 mm let's
take away that f5 square
I think it's useful less than 20 it's
advanced a little bit my Knights
unprotected but any pawn move I take my
bishop d4 Knight c6 is still an idea
maybe right now
not quite let's do this Knight here is a
little bit annoying let's go over right
here and Bishop back and Knight c5 ooh I
better get out of that stuff oh I'm in
trouble that's just a fork that was
silly
there was also Bishop C to threaten
there hmm Knight here just wins material
so they should probably take the rook
here I have to try to keep material on
it's very difficult to even do that I
guess drop the bishop back Knight c5
I'm gonna try to have two I'm gonna try
to hold this with the dark square as
night see five as a threat but it should
be parried quite easily mm-hmm that was
not good at all okay the only thing I
have is dark square control but that
should not be enough at all mmm
tough hill tough a tough uphill battle
here coming up yeah that's the right way
to do it open the files and I don't have
anything to bite at I'm not sure where
my knife belongs I can't really move my
bishop because it enters on e2 they're
low on time just like me mm-hmm
I don't know how to make progress I
kinda have to keep my Bishop sitting
well all I could really do is go back
and forth here okay maybe there's an
opportunity for Knight d4 it's probably
an improvement for the night let's give
a check
I have anything just trying to hold on
tight to these dark squares hmm I have
to keep my pawns sitting right here to
watch over these light squares might be
holding it's an interesting fortress if
it is if that is the case this dark
square controlled and this square
actually okay let's watch over c5 I
don't want to I want to be able to take
with my bishop let's go back
and this is very tough
hmm okay maybe I have to go somewhere
else with my night it's dropping maybe
okay I can't move my knight now Knights
are tricky I'm not threatening to take
yet though maybe now I am not anymore
whoo this one's taking forever
okay maybe get my knight back somewhere
to c5 yeah here comes the break hmm yeah
they're getting the break in there okay
yeah that's an accomplishment for sure
well I could take with my knight maybe I
try to do this keep it closed somewhat
put my bishop here and the rooks going
to get active again and I think you can
they could give check and I'd have to
try something maybe in this direction
the rook is entering maybe not
I'm just banking some time okay my
knight mm-hmm don't not improve them
okay that's another accomplishment right
there they should check I'll reposition
my knight I could have taken the pawn
right there oh I wasn't expecting them
to do that move okay I could take this
guy probably have to get pushing
hmm how do I stop a pond let's go here
first mm-hmm let's go hmm I guess here
don't know ya King right here I don't
have anything guess here yay
this game is taking forever uphill climb
oh well that's simple enough or is this
a
no this isn't a draw is it
what rook ponder they have yeah that was
actually simple enough and they could
actually just push right here yep
pawn push that's time to resign mmm
Knight d3 that was very difficult to
play off the increment like that as
usual but very interesting game I pretty
sure I was better at one point when I
had the control over these dark squares
that Bishop g6 move really rattled me
because there were dual threats Knight
d3 and Bishop to c2 so I wasn't sure
what moved to play there had to have
been something initially I want to play
King g3 I think I was ready to he could
see that during the game King g3 but
then they had Bishop c2 um there was a
better way to reorganize the pieces and
I'm sure the computer will come up with
some suggestions so we'll see what the
suggestions are for both of us because I
think white also could have improved it
excuse me black could have improved that
one
point in that middle game there but I'll
have a look see what we can take away
from this one
okay stockfish show us the way how can
we both improve so we in turn it wasn't
quite in iqp it was more of like a
little hanging pawn structure
I didn't they it wasn't like a hole on
the d4 square that it turned out it
didn't turn out to be a hole on a d4
square in this game with how it played
out h6 was a bit curious for sure yeah I
mean it's not a big fan of that it's
already pointing out 95 piling up on
that night huh
correct rook e1 can't be bad Bishop e6
90 fish at f4 let's have a look at it
this move 95 here breaking the pin then
rook e1 setting up discoveries
Knight takes Queen takes and then taking
here I guess trying to hang on to that
guy castle Bishop e3 94-92 Knight takes
okay so they're getting the pawn back
but I'll be able to play against there
there's some structural imbalance well I
have the bishop pair also bishop hair in
playing against this structure iqp okay
so 95 right away was another interesting
move rook e1 I mean what takes right
away Queen 84 okay doesn't seem to have
too big a problem with this yeah there
is an edge here certainly a pull on the
white end they want to go right in for
an IBD to Knight B to D for that was my
initial thought and I'm like you know
what I want to get rid of the dark
square bishop so I could get to these
squares hmm okay
our han plus night f.2d for not even
reacting hmm oh yeah I'm just seeing it
now if takes this bishop is hit a ton of
times it's following I'll get up on huh
okay what did I do I move backwards okay
Knight d4 King d7 and then f3 even in
this case no because that's what Czech
and still I'm getting something here
didn't see that okay I went back bishop
they're still holding an edge here for
white quite a bit no it doesn't really
like that bishop back here returning I
imagine they would avoid the exchange
again no oh okay takes here Bishop d4
there had to be something it's very
difficult to come up with it though it's
time control these dark squares they're
just both pieces it's like this Bishop
stands good here here the night here
here two pieces have two very good
squares to work with so there's there's
some some way to coordinate them well
hmm interesting
okay so after the binder pieces a pair
of minor pieces come off there is uh
it's easier for black to play slight
only like a slight edge here came there
before yeah I would have been fine with
this
you know there's ideas of rook to be one
rook b6 this night is really well
anchored on d4 it's the mmm typical good
night versus bad Bishop scenario so they
don't take and I don't know how well I
voiced it during the game but I was
thinking after this here if this type of
idea to try and gain control the a file
I had in mind at night b3 but I was
mistaken without because
I was thinking they would have to make a
capture like this due to the pressure on
a5 but they have the a5 secured if this
night was in a different position this
is a nice if you could just envision the
night on c7 this idea to resolve the
tension putting pressure on 85 with
night b3 forcing let's just say a
capture then they're not going to have
clear access to the a file they're not
going to get that rook activity so
easily there's a capture again this is
envisioning a knight on c7 where he
doesn't have control of a5 I could
contest a file like this he's
inconvenience for a bit but I'm still
holding on the dark squares yeah okay
well the night wasn't on c7 but anyhow
that was my idea and that's what I was
thinking and it was a poor thought
because it wasn't their knight was
defending 85 okay 93 yeah what should I
have done here so this is clearly where
it turns just the one one move threat
here and then you deed three what should
I have done here Bishop d4 oh good grief
Knight here with check gets out of any
Forks here in situ hmm okay I didn't see
that I didn't seem
moving the bishop by the way and getting
out of this stuff with a check and king
here and then I could meet the threat
this Knight is doing so many things hmm
watching over d3 pressure on a6 mm-hmm
okay so after this night d3 they're off
the exchange and it's still tough to
crack clearly you can see it with the
evaluation only because I have that dark
square control and well this game goes
nearly 100 moves I won't be going over
every move from here but eventually as
soon as that c4 breakout in successfully
and another file opened up and that rook
got active that's where it was too much
couldn't defend let's just go a little
bit faster from here it may pop up it
just did popped up a zero but that's
because it it's thinking oh it was
repetition draw but that's not really a
true assessment I'm just checking real
quick here to see if I missed any Forks
along the way any tactical shots for me
and so far no there really wasn't much I
could do I didn't really see an active
plan I mean not until the very end where
I had an opportunity to take on d5
when the bishop left from the c-4 square
but like right here I could take on d5
but even so it's still you know blacks
in the driver's seat and Ike takes here
ripp takes h4 past each pawn king takes
here okay maybe given a check running
right into this yikes I can't see myself
playing this 12 hmm here takes King g5
maybe somehow I could hold a draw off my
bishop gets here okay but
rook is probably really quick to get
here yeah there's a fork mm-hmm okay
yeah I can't see myself going for that
variation into a going right in for
going into a discovered check but I
think see - yeah nothing else was missed
as soon as that h pond gets rolling and
then yeah I didn't even that's just very
clean technique simplified give the
material back I'm tethered to the
defense to that each pond the night is a
he absolutely hates defending against
that and I did had nothing but yeah
missed opportunity to find a good
coordination is the big thing with this
one working into those c5 and d4 squares
maybe I should look into having the
night on c5 I know just the other day
when streaming I was pointing out these
ideal squares for a night the c4 c4 c5
f4 f5 you know c5 squared a fantastic
square for a night I should have gone
there but I don't know had my Bishop
there it seemed like it was functioning
well on that square as well but in the
end I didn't find a good way to
coordinate those pieces on those squares
and I I missed that
Bishop d4 move when they were
threatening that fork on d3 and the fork
on c2 but anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any comments in the comment
section below to this video and as
always I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now
take care
you